[Music]
up
[Music]
way
oh look at that hello welcome to moses
and friends
people are on let's do this okay i'm
your host moses storm welcome to the
show guys we are
live on twitch youtube live and facebook
which apparently is still a thing
uh welcome to your data harvesting
session
uh if you haven't been here before this
is the show where we take all of our
favorite people
from the conan show we put them up live
maybe they're just
friends of the world or podcast and
we get to talk to them we have some
great friends on the show tonight
we have uh you know from designated
survivor all seasons on netflix uh nbc
sunnyside which i hear
is great harold and kumar go to white
castle he also
briefly worked in the uh obama
administration
only guest to have a real job kalpan is
on
uh but first i'm gonna talk to my very
funny friend who has a special out on
netflix
right now recorded right before the
shutdown
it's called three in the morning sam j
is here uh before we get to sam j
real quick want to talk to you guys
because you are honestly the first
people
i have talked to today what uh
we're live in the chat if you guys have
any questions for me uh bazinga seems to
be the hottest comment
this all seems like tbs bots that are
trying to
push a a syndication uh i want to talk
to you guys about
um well i guess drive-in movies
so there's been a big push for comedians
to perform at drive-in movie theaters
and get honked at we talked about that
a couple weeks back a lot of people are
going to drive in movies
i want to hear your experience so put
this in the chat what are you going
through
are you actually able to enjoy the movie
and what are you seeing
uh at this time because i've only been
to one one drive-in movie theater
and this is on a date this is uh the
year
that whatever year shutter island came
out and i thought it'd be like a
like a hot date right to take a girl to
a drive-in movie theater but this is
obviously before the shutdown so time
had forgotten
about driving movie theaters so what i
showed up to
was an abandoned wasteland there was not
only no one there but there was
a number of cats and i want to say a
number without exaggerating
um but uh it's just like 9 000 stray
cats
that were there's no light way to put
this
assaulting each other physically
assaulting each other and they screamed
through the
entire movie and there's just like
scraps of food around
and the girl i was with katie hi oh
she's not watching okay
uh it was like uh maybe we should just
like
get some food uh because cats had
screamed us out of the movie
but i hear they've gotten better so
who's been to uh who's been to a
drive-in movie theater
dragons are coming back says shannon
yeah okay so like what what's the
experience like now they cleaned up
their act
because uh so also like all these old
movies are being released
so here's here's a real thing my
producer sent me this about the movies
that are these are the top grossing
movies of the summer of 2020 just
because this is like
the year that we're in a little bit of a
flash from the past
we have uh back to the future jurassic
park
uh greece and the goonies
so these movies are back now i want to
know okay
one what is your drive-in movie
experiment like what's what's the what's
the experience like for you
also do these movies that are being
re-released in 2020
with 2020 vision uh do they hold up
what's what's going on what are some of
the movies that maybe
don't hold up uh so
anything is better than than nothing i
mean that's why we're
technically doing this show we are live
on twitch as well we're on
hello youtube people hello twitch people
over there
uh a lot of you are not familiar with
twitch i found that out the hard way
twitch is it's it's worse than tick tock
uh better than quibby is the best i can
explain it
and we've been having a great time on
here
tick tock is is getting banned has
anyone gotten banned from
uh tick tock yet i don't think
yeah okay what are we saying
uh no i don't think the tick tock band
will actually work
well because it's like teens that are
running it right it's like a mainly it's
like a teen app
at least all the people i cruise around
and watch it's teens and like
honestly good luck banning a teen app
because it's like
one so teens run it so
what's that yeah yeah
well okay so like yeah i think tw i
think teens are gonna find a way
around the ban for one like let's not
forget like a teen
hacked all of verified twitter bill
gates
joe biden got to find out he had a
twitter account
and uh eli musk also got hacked as well
which uh yeah i think that's what tipped
everything off twitter officials knew
that eli musk got hacked because he
started tweeting things that were like
vaguely empathetic towards human beings
like whoa
something something's wrong this is
severely
off-brand for elon musk
yeah no i did see the tweet yeah
jonathan
so yeah so elon me elon musk tweeted uh
another government stimulus package is
not in the best interest of the people
so we shouldn't give people more money
even though we're forbidding them to
work which i could not agree with more
honestly that's been my biggest problem
with this whole pandemic is i've had
just
too much money what am i going to do
with it right now you can't really see
but i'm sitting in a
scrooge mcduck pile of coins right now
too much money i mean honestly it's just
like
yeah yes billionaires are out of touch
well
here's the thing it's like joe biden
yeah he found out he had a twitter
well like the thing with elon musk is
like yes he's
he is a smart person and you know he
makes a great car
but like honestly most most geniuses are
that are like torture geniuses torture
themselves and not us with these
awful awful tweets yeah
uh welcome to the world of welfare thank
you
toaster appreciate it what do we got
there's almost two it's going i
absolutely agree yeah yeah
yes everything that elon musk has ever
said including
endorsing someone that's clearly going
through a mental collapse
david newar definitely definitely solid
solid agree with that
yeah okay all right so
let's get back to movies what are we
what are we talking about with movies
what have you seen
in in in a movie theater that's actually
held up
or maybe going to a drive-in what have
we seen
and i'm going to ask you guys a question
too through the chat
actually what do you see what is
yeah okay so what's up what's the movie
that maybe it doesn't hold up i've been
seeing some things
that maybe uh in the 2020
eyes would not work well i recently
re-watched because you know i have the
time
and big joanna man fan uh
don't imagine that going over well at
the drive-in movie theater
and he says the abyss holds up i haven't
seen this what is the abyss
serious i'm guessing by serious this is
a dad
only dads listen to siriusxm which is
honestly
dad's great way to ban tick-tock
you build a dab wall that's the only way
you're ever gonna ban
tick-tock the quickest way to make a
social media app
not cool is to add your parents to it
like i remember a time when facebook was
a
was the place where people were like
doing sex on each other
and then now you go to facebook and it's
just like your aunt
screaming about q anon and pizzagate
yeah that's the title of this la
uh the last polar bear that's a real
movie
i think if we add dads yes absolutely if
you could
if you could if we can get all of our
fathers to sign up
for it for tick tock it's gone tomorrow
100
i give it 10 seconds what are some
things that we could get dads like
what's an incentive we could get to get
dads to sign up for tick tock
yes uh yeah i think yeah we make a
package for dads like we say
first we lure them in with videos of
like minor car problems and we're like
what's this thing that could fix like
it's actually the battery not the
alternator
and then we give them like a nice nice
package
yeah what's what's the stuff that dad's
like
uh yeah well okay so yeah so for dads we
we give them like
to get them to sign up for tick tock we
give them like those like uh what are
those like holsters for the cell phones
transition lenses and those jeans that
they they only sell at costco and who's
buying those
dads are we get a bunch of dads on tick
tock we made
we'd make a dad wall the exorcist
doesn't hold up how does that not hold
up
thunder tick tock package
conan tick tock uh now deleted tomorrow
let's get conan tick tock
yeah i don't think uh that would go too
well
yeah dad sneakers for sure we get some
new balance the chunkiest new balances
you've ever seen
they weigh six pounds out of the box
uh yeah my dad is conan but he refuses
to
uh to uh claim me as his child adam
but you know thank you for bringing that
up we're just trying to start a show
here
yeah not sure where to go is personally
a
car repair home repair yeah we get some
home depot people
in there to get dads on tick tock it's
just like home depot people
every time you you're in there the
employees just run away from you
i think that'll be good uh how do you
feel about starship troopers
i don't think the movie holds up i think
it's a good drive-in movie
because it doesn't uh it you know it's
not great special effects but that's
like part of the fun you could talk with
your date that's about to leave you
i don't think there's anything else like
overtly wrong like she's the man
recently watched that and uh found out i
have a very big and feminine face
so i look essentially like amanda bynes
in a wig
which i have no problem with jay leno
jyn saves the wall
yeah let's get does jayla i don't have a
tick tock i would love to see that
okay what are some last movies last
movies that don't hold up you've seen
recently because you're in quarantine
maybe you're going to it let's let's get
them out
been completely ignoring twitch
because it's an irrelevant app let's see
uh
swamp raiders is that a movie
giant magnets oh giant magnus for dad
got it swamp raiders these are all dad
things breakfast club yeah what so
what's the deal with breakfast club
doesn't doesn't hold up
a little uh a little creepy
in the light of day weather reports
this is great there's always too many
guys gone with the wind
oof oof that does not hold up that whole
era even like the shirley temple era
does not hold up it's just so creepy
watching it with like
there's just like a child in in boomers
around these
grown men armageddon doesn't hold up
these all these movies hold up i
disagree with
maximum override does not hold up these
are some deep cuts i don't think
was maximum override a blockbuster hit
spaceballs why why don't these movies
hold up if spaceballs doesn't hold by
it's just like corny
courtney jokes you photobomb caught on
selfie
million subscribers yeah that's nice
okay i want to bring my first guest
in because this is let's get down here
this is great so my first
guest couldn't be happy to have her here
she has a special on netflix it was
actually recorded
right before the lockdown like the
perfect time
right before the lockdown so you don't
have to do like all the the covered
material that everyone's gonna have to
do
and uh yeah she's i watched it last
night it's incredible it's really great
it's on netflix right now it's called
three in the morning
let's welcome sam jay into the room
let's continue this so let's welcome sam
jay sam do we have you
i'm good how are you moses you look cute
thank you
thank you so much i'm wearing about four
hours worth of makeup right now you look
that face did look beat
it did it did it i've been taking a hit
you look great you look like you just
cyber bullied some 12 year olds on
call of duty modern that's what i'm
about
this is very fitting for twitch this is
the look
i didn't know how weak my sauce was
until i've had to follow
you on stage oh boo that's so cute
yeah like i've lied to house before i'm
like oh i have a thing just so i didn't
have to
follow you because like once you get up
there it's impossible to go up there
with my [ __ ]
like we're pretty poor guys
you do a really great thing where you
you are very present
you talk to the crowd in the moment how
much of that carried over to the special
which is something that's like
this big thing in your mind like this is
take forever
i really feel like it's still carried
over like i just really still tried to
stay in the moment
i think a person that really helped me
with that like randomly is bill burr i
had called them like
maybe four days before kind of like
freaking out you know what i mean like
on some real like nerd freaking out
stuff and i was like
can i send you like the whole thing and
can you just like listen to it and like
tell me if it's terrible and he was like
you don't i don't need to do that you
know what i mean like
he was just like kind of on some chill
out and he was basically he said to me
the thing that he said that stuck with
me was he said
all you're doing is marking where your
set is
at this moment in time that's a really
great way to think about it
he was like you're gonna feel like you
missed things you're gonna watch it and
feel like oh i should have said that or
i flubbed this line he's like it's just
impossible not to do that kind of stuff
but he's like all you're doing is
marking where your set is in this moment
at this time and that's that's all it is
and once i kind of embrace that energy
of it it took a lot of that kind of
weight off of me
and allowed me to just be natural in the
way that i
am and i think it truly did help at all
yeah to be present
in that moment and it's a great way to
think about it like hey listen this is
where i'm at
right now and not thinking right i get
another special after this will i be
able to tour
right right exactly you taped a special
in atlanta versus
boston where you're from what was the
thought behind that
i just didn't want to be bothered with
my family i just felt like it was too
seriously it was just too many my
grandmother had 11 kids i grew up there
my whole life
i've got tons of friends and i just
didn't want to be overwhelmed by people
i wanted to be able to focus on the
thing i had to do
yeah and just perform in a fun city
people feel weird about talking about
people on stage
knowing that they're in the crowd like
family members like actually this is how
it happened it's like well your version
of what happened is not funny
right and no i don't i don't i think the
only person that i'm concerned about
when it comes to stuff like that
is my girlfriend because i live with her
yeah
but other than that no
don't worry about it so have you guys if
you had family members
reach out to you and be like um actually
why did you say this and just like i
don't care
i mean i don't ever put them in it in a
real way i have 11 cousins so i'll say
one of my cousins
now if you you the guilty party then you
just know you the guilty party you know
what i mean
i'll say my aunt i have seven aunts you
know like
i don't ever put a name to the person
you know
right you're not putting people on
blasts no no no i don't put anyone on
blast
i remember a very specific set this one
i was like just getting to know you i
think it was 2017
montreal which is where comedians would
be today
if this wasn't happening it's the
biggest comedy festival you were part of
the new faces
me and jack never in the balcony and it
was very rough because everyone was
bombing their new faces sets this big
opportunity you get where you basically
tell the world who you are
you get five minutes and it was rough
and people were bombing left and right
and then you got up there
and you're supposed to do like the
cleanest version of your set of like
what would my
sitcom be and you just started talking
about your divorce
in a very real way and crushed harder
than i've
ever seen anyone crush a new faces set
uh incredible oh that's true what was
the thought going
before that cause i only talked to you
afterwards i've talked to you before
of like was there a [ __ ] part of you
or was there
of like this is the only thing that's
gonna work right now i mean
one i was that was the set i was gonna
do that's what i had been preparing to
do to go into new faces and like
i'm just a firm believer of like i can't
be doing [ __ ] i don't do
because if i win doing something i don't
do then i'm always gonna have to do that
thing and i'm gonna be miserable and if
that's the case and i might as well go
back to working at the john hancock meal
room
so like why even why even sat down that
road
so it was kind of like i just got to
present this my way and like do it how i
do it because
that's the way if i'm going to win i
want to win you know what i mean
yeah and i felt like also i was invited
and you know what i do
like i haven't changed it up so why
would you think i would get on stage
all of a sudden now and come out you
know talking like
um some super clean comic like that just
didn't make sense to me to approach it
that way right but before it was
nerve-wracking and people were being
crazy and i knew that most of those
people were gonna bomb
i've never got to say this publicly but
i really did please please please please
i knew that most of those people were
gonna bomb and not because they weren't
good but because of the energy that was
back in that room it was nuts everybody
was on edge
it was the craziest vibe i had ever felt
and i'm like
you can't have fun on stage like this
this is
insane so i left i left that room that
they were holding us in and i went down
to the bar
and i was drinking and just like talking
to people that were like
coming in and trying to like go sit down
and stuff and i was just hanging out
treating it like a regular
thursday night at the improv because i
was like i can't be bothered with all
this craziness
and i think that helped like alleviate
my brain of all
that nut stuff like i think that's an
important thing if there's any comic
watching it's like put yourself in the
energy that works for you like don't
don't feel like you have to sit in that
madness because that's that's
what's insane very important that i
learned from you
and one of the only reasons i got to
talk to you in the first place was that
because we have a lot of mutual friends
so we do the same shows but you always
would talk to just anyone that's around
and i happen to be anyone
right before you go on stage so you're
talking like yourself
so i grew up half irish and half person
yeah yeah no no one talks like that
yeah yeah and that does help it's like i
i like that pace like i like to be in
the middle of a conversation they're
like you're next and i'm like cool
and i could just like go up and like do
my thing i like that pacing of energy
because it
it does keep me in the moment you know
have you been out to any of the the
protests
um no i i have lupus so one i just
really haven't been out much
period and not want to really be risky
out there like that so no i haven't
um but not to say that if i didn't i
necessarily would be like i've gone to
them in the past
and i just find myself to be more
effective in other ways
yeah as far as i think that's what a lot
of you know
people with money could do it's like
yeah put your money where you're
not like insert yourself into the
conversation have you seen any white
cringe
allies online because i have seen some
i mean online is just all cringe
everything
you know the whole thing is just like
ugh like that of course i was asking
that you said
yes and also like that
yeah for real and also like the
explanations of like
it's like white people are always
annoying with information
no matter the information they're just
like annoying
information and
it's like just all the research that
they're newly doing and just trying to
like
tell you about yourself a little bit is
just like annoying and there's a lot of
moves that i'm like um
i don't know if we really cared that
much about that
like don't be taking all the flags away
from the nascar people
like i get no car could have a
confederate flag
but don't tell people they can't wear
one one that helps me identify
people who i should not be around if i
did go to
a nascar rally it's very nice and very
easy for me to know no
also as a black person it's unsettling
like
don't take away all the white people's
like these poor white people need
something
because you take away their confederate
flag that's you know their lynching
like just let them hold on to their
little piece or whatever they got
and that's fine the flag is better
than murdering a human being right it's
like maybe
no you can't have it over state capital
because that state capital represents
everybody but if you don't want the
confederate flag to drape over his man
boobs and represent him
by all means let him do that absolutely
yeah the flag is a helpful
reminder it's a contact tracing for
racism of like yes this is a racist
person stay awake
yeah i don't want to get into a
conversation and learn about this person
no
i love when i see someone ride by with
the flag of their car and a gun it's
like don't drive by him
go that way good to know so as far as
like
what i mean white people are stepping
down from voice over jobs
and jemima's cancelled i mean in the
bigger picture how
helpful is that or is that a cop out and
like oh i have to do anything else
because i did this one thing
i think it's a little above i do think
it's helpful in the sense of like
i do think it's helpful for white people
being aware of like my privilege
is getting me things that other people
are not having access to
and if i actually want to be helpful
then i need to
recognize that and then do something
about it and not just
recognize it so i do like the action
behind it
but then again like you're saying it
goes too far like we had to cancel uncle
ben
and that really messed me up because one
it's all perception
i never saw him as a man servant i
thought he was the runner of a rice
company
he had a suit on i was like a
distinguished
black man that made good rice like i
really never
put the other stank on it with that and
i was proud to eat uncle ben's i'm like
look at me supporting this
batman and his good rice but apparently
it was
it was some white people rice right well
i think it's for white people it's like
well
now i don't have to do the really
uncomfortable thing that's why i'm like
standing up for black people in my life
because i did this one thing of this
thing has nothing to do with
rice that white people don't even eat
uncle ben has too much seasoning
right that's what i i always felt like
it was the black rice and i had all like
the black stuff in my home we had uncle
[ __ ]
if they had a black face on it we would
buy it and that was probably
the white man's propaganda but i did
like having a black man on my rice
it's comforting so i think yes it's a
sure white people should not play people
that are not
people of color in voiceover but i don't
even know about that
i don't 100 agree with that i just think
we're at a time where these things need
to be
shifted and so they're shifting but i
hope we get to a time where like
people could just be doing what they
want you know like i think that's the
ultimate goal like i don't
i don't think it should be a thing like
i was talking to alex english and he was
like well i'm tired of straight actors
playing gay actors i'm like
why can't it's acting you know i mean i
was like i think the problem is there's
not
enough roles and gay people aren't
getting roles and so it's frustrating
and then you see a straight actor
playing role and you're frustrated but i
would like to see
gay actors play straight actors and
straight out like because it's
that's the art form and a part of why
you want to act is to
be something that you are not and
portray something that is not
necessarily
you so we got all the white people just
being white and all the black people
just being black and all the gay people
just being gay then we can just watch
[ __ ] in their actual life and
we don't really need to see them
portray or project anything else you
know so i hope we progress to a place
where we're
we are a true equality happens where
we're fine with all that
because i think we start to tiff and
fight over those little things because
we're not
experiencing equality in our day to day
and if we were then we would care
way less about that kind of stuff that
is very very well said
i mean yes i mean that is 100
agree with that the other thing is like
uh i learned this from
touring with like you jack and and chris
is like
yes uh do you think it'd be positive if
comedian white comedians stepped down
from doing a black scent
on stage i just think it's dumb and
hacky so
like just don't just don't do it because
it's stupid anyone not familiar a white
comedian
who looks just like me would be like
yeah man you already
know this [ __ ] is like what are you
doing
[Laughter]
what and i mean just don't do that we
were in i think it was san diego and you
were just like
no from the back of the room
just don't do that might actually be
helpful
indeed this is really great talking to
you i mean this was fun
i really trust you i trust people that
have called me a [ __ ] to my face
right i remember once ever at jack's
taping i was wearing a quilted dress
shirt
uh one of the many mistakes i've made
and you're like moses you're such a
[ __ ] wearing a
quilted dress shirt so i respect you
ever since then and love you more than
anything so thank you so much for
doing this you know donna's daughter is
a is a album you already have out and
then
newly three in the morning is on netflix
right now sam jay thank you so much
thanks bye so my next guest
very excited to have him here my former
boss good friend of mine someone i've
talked to
through this whole quarantine please
welcome kalpan
what's up moses storm how are you you're
writing this out in new york
every day that i facetime you have been
trying to convince you to get out of
new york yeah well now with now it's
fine
you were right for you know what two and
a half months
now new york is absolutely crushing it
in numbers
it's not fine i just want to be clear
and for everybody watching who's like oh
we should just go
to new york it's still not fine but yeah
it's been everyone should come there and
should go clubbing is what i heard
right that's the message we'll put out
cal pen says covet is a hoax will be
the clickbait article in fact if
anything i just want everybody
from the rest of the country to please
not come to new york new jersey or
connecticut
like please don't come here we worked
very hard without you
to get this down you went and [ __ ] up
your own states and now that's on you
so please don't come here you gotta let
not all of california but la
new york we're half the school l.a is
terrible right now because they just
keep going
up it's so sad it's more embarrassing
now because it's supposed to be people
that are like hyper liberal
over cautious i don't give my kid any
gluten or sunlight because that's
all those people are intending but
there's so there's that right but then
the more obvious
the more obvious thing that confuses me
about la
is you don't interact with humans i
lived in l.a for 12
years you're in your car all the time or
you're in your apartment
people rarely walk how are you guys
spreading this
because they are still hotter in la so
people cannot help but smash each other
yeah you're garbage you're used to
having as a performer and i see
a lot of down time so you can just kind
of shift into like oh yeah this is a
time where i'm working or i just got
canceled for something 2003.
but uh so i want to know have you picked
up any hobbies
skills that have nothing to do with your
career something that takes your money
completely off it that maybe are not
going to benefit you at all it's not
like i'm gonna learn meisner technique
uh yeah i i mean
yeah keeping in mind i know the answer
to this question already
from our facetime call last week
is it the cookie purchases you have made
on
amazon anything that maybe
is centered oh no he's going to look for
it you're talking about my puppet
oh yes let me get it you know him you
love him
worked in the white house at one point
puppet let me get this [ __ ] puppet
hold on this
is um oh yeah this is where is he
i know you can hear me hold on super
strength
oh my god okay is a purchase i told him
not to do
right before he was making it he was
three beers deep
he'd already purchased uh several wigs
for sketch characters
yeah so and when he said when you said
um
when you said have i have i been working
on anything or purchasing purchased
anything that has
nothing to do with our career i i
you know he he quickly popped into my
mind and i thought well that does sort
of have something to do with our careers
because we're actors
and nobody
i mean it's pretty solid character just
for the record
you are the only person friend or
otherwise
who is remotely amused by that's not
true
uh slosh was very amused by him
was was also musical because a puppet is
such a big commitment
like if jeff dunham ran for office right
it would still be like oh the puppet guy
yeah yeah yeah such a clear chef
oh the puppet guy uh-huh yeah yeah
forget
everything you've done in your career
you're not the puppet guy
it's so that's maybe the like
you know when you're when you're tell me
if you're the same i assume the answer
is yes but like
you know that that that cliche of like
oh uh
i want to be an actor or comedian or
really any art
insert any artist versus like i have to
do this
like there's a part of my brain and soul
that needs
to express myself this way or tell
stories or whatever it is
that like that's the one thing that i
think
not being able to do is where you end up
buying a puppet on amazon for 10 bucks
right because it's like where where am i
getting that outlet
and it was and this started like that
puppet's been super handy for a lot of
my friends and
cousins who have kids where it's like
hey story time
but then that [ __ ] gets old right and
you're like i have nothing
yeah which is in normal circumstances
very creepy
really just unfortunate and weird so
we're gonna put your gofundme up if you
guys want to donate
it's really having a full-on meltdown
kalpan the puppet guy
and not the respected actor and former
white house
employee and then um i think i think
just speaking
about progressiveness
yeah we're at a point uh industry-wise
it's something that you could speak on
uh where the industry is getting a lot
more progressive with the with the
movements and the
the peaceful protests have been going on
where
it's taken effect on the industry where
now actors are stepping down from
voiceover roles that are
white actors playing people of color
because i think what you were telling me
is that early in your career when you
were coming up there
wasn't the option i mean things are not
even close to what they should be now as
far as
inclusion and people of color getting
the jobs they deserve
but you didn't even have the discussion
around the time that you were coming up
it was just like here's this character
do you want a career
do this yeah there was a project i did
that that
required an accent and i i took it uh
and i did some research on what the
accent would sound like and then i get
an email from the producers it's like
hey here's the dialect coach you're
going to to make sure that you can learn
the accent i show up to this office and
it's this
old white woman who's teaching me how to
do an indian accent
yeah i i wish you know what i wonder if
i still have the tape somewhere
but it was doing it and then she doing
like actually it's like this well she
would do it first
but but at the time the thing that's
interesting now when i look at like
you know how how people seem to be
realizing that this is not a good idea
is that i was obviously very bothered by
it at the time
but i also just felt exhausted by it
where again it's like oh i thought maybe
i was going to a dialect coach
the same way that you do in drama school
because you have a role coming up
and maybe you mumble yeah and
i realized very quickly i'm like i don't
have the luxury of you mumble
because they just want this accent the
way that they want it
right so it's like that's the constant
thing that that i think sometimes is
missed in these conversations
about identity which is the bottom line
is we all want really great storytelling
we want compelling storytelling
you know network tv is very slow to
catch up to this a lot of the
the paid and streaming services
especially especially netflix and amazon
have been very forward thinking about
diverse casting
and it's worked for them i think because
audiences are sick of seeing
the same cookie-cutter type of shows so
that doesn't even necessarily mean
diversity at face value and hopefully
it's not just diversity of face value
it's like
characters that come from totally
different walks of life interacting in
ways that we haven't seen before
in brutally honest ways ways that make
the storytelling more interesting and
more lively and
and just make us better like what do you
want out of tv what do you want out of
your
out of your experience you want to feel
something you want to laugh you want to
you know it's all of that that i think
is just better served
when you have casting that's that that
that reflects our experiences
well that's what i i really got to see
firsthand on
on the show that i worked out that with
you at your show
where it was like okay yeah it's a
diverse show and outside of all the
clickbait articles and like picture the
show's like it's the most diverse cast
it's immigrants with the exception of me
who looks like the son of gavin newsom
uh the when's your onset all those
articles go away and it just
becomes those actors are just the best
people for this job
yeah it has nothing to do with their
backgrounds born in ethiopia it's like
no that's just a funny good actor
and we should give more opportunities
for those people to shine
if you do it right i think that's what
you end up with right
if you uh you know there are
i've several friends who in the last
couple years
uh have you know you'll get like
you'll have like a passing comment from
one of your one of your white actor
friends like i auditioned for that movie
i didn't get it cause i'm white i'm like
oh yeah i can relate
oh but you still own everything you
still control all of everything
right sorry so my first reaction is i
can relate from the last 15 years of my
career
i get it like yeah no that's not fair
like that means that like
i'm just gonna have to i'm just gonna to
try
harder you're gonna have to try now
yeah there are some uh what do what if
people in politics say they have such
fun uh and by fun i mean insufferable
ways of describing things
uh oh those are the industries going
through some growing pains
like no the [ __ ] sucks for a lot of
people um but
that's part of i think what ultimately
will make better
art and storytelling yes more people are
represented
i want to play a game with you before we
get out of here is
that you get asked the same just just
from like doing props with you you
yeah help i get asked the same hack
questions
over and over again there's about four
of them that you can
ask over and over again and i want to
play a game with you called hack back
clap back where first you'll give the
hack answer that you have to give
because you don't want to hurt that
interviewer's
feelings because obviously they want to
be an actor but now they're hosting this
show
right and then you get the clap back
it's the real answer
no consequences it's not directed to any
person
if there's no consequence you could say
exactly
what you felt in that moment so first
you give the
pr answer and then you give the clap
back okay
so your first hack back clap back
question is okay so
harold and kubot this is the guy by the
way all right i know that guy
so you played harold keyboard you're the
white castle
i would ask are you gonna ask a question
gotta ask legally uh
are you high right now oh
i'm not i'm not you know i gotta have a
meeting okay so that's the hack answer
and now you give the clap back question
i gotta ask you gal you're high right
now
really high really really really high
i'm really high i'm really [ __ ] high
dude
man you gotta give me some money man
come on okay
so you've had quite the interesting
career i mean cal you went from
white castle to the white house that was
how i
happy hal yeah it was you know it was
such an honor
um yeah i was i i'm just so glad that uh
you know the the i i am fortunate enough
to
have the chance to do a lot of the
things that i that i wanted to do i'm
i'm having a hard time answering this
move because right that is how i feel
let's get to it then let's get to it
before you say another word
what is the clapback question kelly you
went from the white house oh white
castle to the white house what was that
like
yeah that headline is not clever it's
not clever it's
every there's a i have a i have a
running tally with a couple of friends
i try to take a picture when i sometimes
when i do interviews
the host you do it with will have the
prompter pulled up
and i can see about four seconds before
they introduce me
there's a thing that pops up is it all
kind of oh yeah all caps
our next guest went from the white
castle to the white house and they
always do the head bob
when they go from one to the other and
uh
i die a little bit inside um but it's
also funny
yeah it's also funny because it's like
yeah i mean they're not doing art
there's no malice in there yeah yeah
it's obama cool
is he a cool guy you see him he's
dropping mics
is he a cool guy account you're
scoliosis now
yeah okay
okay so now the clap back question is
about a cool guy is he a guy
could do me with a huge dick actually
no he's not he's not but sometimes i say
that just to watch people's faces fall
right
um and especially especially
uh especially drunk women which you know
obviously you're thinking how often do
you encounter drunk women you live in
manhattan it's thursday through sunday
yeah but that's always a fun one
because it comes from such a good place
of like uh look at the [ __ ] we're
dealing with now hey
you you know you work for obama like
tell me something good
and so when you when i just go dark with
like oh god no
they're watching their faces follow
those prices i i pick back up i pick it
up before i move on but
huge dick you know he's really into
youtube
cyber bullying he's always got a fidget
spinner on you know
he's always chugging a monster energy
drink and that's obama's secret
okay cal last question for you you know
you're on a house right and it's always
medical jargon
if you're on a plane and someone's
having a allergic reaction to peanuts
do you ever you ever ever ever get asked
to step in
medically yeah
uh sometimes sometimes yeah
oh cow there you go
it's a cow you've worked on house you
learned all that medical jargon here are
you ever
forced to step in in a medical emergency
oh no oh no puppets out puppet can say
whatever he wants
can't cancel a puppet that was your
[ __ ] question
oh oh look how clever i am
mouse's storm hey [ __ ]
that's not that's not nice i shouldn't
i'm not nice yeah here i am
that's that's not necessary we can i
think we figured it out you got to bring
the puppet with you
said that the the fun thing about
that question recently is
um so i did a graduation speech at
quinnipiac university
i want to say two years three years ago
yeah you know yeah
well that's not a humble brag i got paid
money and i gave a speech i did one i
am available phoenix yeah did you
okay so when i show up there and it was
like it was really fun and i
enjoy doing these things and it's a fun
side gig
um they they gave me an honorary
doctorate
and so i have been trying to figure out
for the last two years
the next time i renew my driver's
license can i put
doctor instead of mr am i allowed to do
that
and my understanding is that
you sort of choose your title nobody
verify you have to send a diploma
but even if you did it's a thing that
says
it's honorary but it says you're an
honorary doctor so like
if he said all of us could do that we
could all go i could go dr
moses storm
but i am in fact the doctor and so
when somebody on a plane asks if there's
a doctor on board
i'm really [ __ ] with the puppet
psycho attempted to hit the button i
want to hit the button
it's no longer it's no longer the
overused question that people ask me
because i was on the house
it is now me really really wanting the
next flight i'm on
to have some sort of a medical emergency
just so i can introduce myself yeah
as a doctor but what's the plan you
actually get there someone's like their
necks blowing up from a peanut allergy
and
get the same scent no and they're like
you're like doctor doctor what do we do
i'm like well i'm uh i'm an honorary
doctor of letters
from quinnipiac university
i can talk to the patient the patient
can talk he's dying it's
and then it's not a good outcome huh
the puppet gives mouth to mouth yeah
like i mean yeah yeah
it suddenly becomes a nathan for you
sketch with not a good outcome
right psycho cal pen
what a time for it this is really great
talking to you thanks gail
and thank you to sam jay for joining us
that's gonna do it for us thank you guys
so much for for tuning into the show
we will be back again because these are
a lot of fun i'm moses storm good night
[Music]
you